huge sea dragon emerges from british
wildlife park as an employee runs into
the remains of a 180 million year old
predator
my colleague thought the ridges we saw
were probably just pipes when the
paleontologists and our team uncovered
the full skeleton and lifted it out
using a tractor with a loader the head
was as large as me and i am six feet
tall
this color loan weighs a ton
with a 10 meter long fossilized body
the remains belonged to an ichthyosaur
a huge dolphin-like reptile that was a
predator in the dinosaur world
enormous teeth allowed it to prey even
on its own kind
rutland ichthyosaur is the largest
skeleton ever found in the uk
it is a truly unprecedented discovery it
was practically complete to the tip of
the tail with the sea dragon sparking so
much interest among paleontologists
is it too soon to pray they don't try to
reincarnate it